we are back revisiting a play from early
on in golden state and memphis and this
is the dillon
on gary payton
jr
nephew was playing so well too
i feel for brooks was ejected
steve kerr
on the injury
[Music]
you know he'll have an mri tomorrow
but it's confirmed that he's got a
fractured elbow and the mri will help
determine
how long gary will be out
do you think that was
intentional to try to hurt him
i don't know if it was intentional but
it was dirty and um
you know
playoff basketball is gonna it's
supposed to be physical you know
everybody's gonna compete and
everybody's gonna fight for everything
but there's a code in this league
there's a code
that players
follow um
where you never
put a guy's
season slash career in jeopardy by
taking somebody out in midair
and clubbing them across the head and
ultimately fracturing
mary's elbow this is a guy who's been
toiling
the last six years trying to make it in
this league
finally found a home
just you know playing his butt off this
year
um
in the playoffs you know this should be
the time of his life
and
a guy comes in and
whacks him across the head in midair he
broke the code dylan brooks broke the
code
did you break the code
yes sir no
there is a code there when the guy's in
midair listen when guy's in midair and
you're bigger than him and you touch him
physics take over definitely gonna what
did he do
he wound up
he hit him in the head did he do it on
purpose no let's say he wound up and you
know he blocked the shot it had been a
good block but one he didn't jump he did
hit him in the head so yes he broke the
goal but did he break it on purpose and
try to hurt young fella i don't think so
i agree with him guys been you know he's
been a journeyman for a long time he
finally has a home
uh
got to be more careful on those plays
but
you know i just think it was unfortunate
that he hit him in the head did he break
the code no
it was just an accident i don't think
dylan brooke is a dirty player he
doesn't have that reputation but first i
want to say guys when you fall out the
air please don't try to catch yourself
that's one thing we talked about when i
first got to the 76 they're like guys
when you fall
get your hands up because elbows fingers
and wrists they will give and you will
break them fall on your shoulders fall
on your back following your ass they can
take hard fault he tried to catch
himself can't do that but
i don't think he tried to hurt him i
think he tried
man the code is we don't try to hurt
each other
and dylan brooks has never proven to me
he's a dirty player
sometimes you hit a guy and he gets hurt
and i think that was an accident
that's just my opinion
and listen steve has to protect this
player but i i've been how many years
we've been watching dylan brooks
a lot
i don't think he don't have a reputation
as a dirty out there trying to hurt a
reputation as an as an aggressive
defender
it was kind of out of line in terms of
defenseless player going up for layup
and him taking a huge wind up and
everything that
everything bad that could have happened
in that situation did knocked him out of
the game you know see what happens with
uh his injury
obviously a tough way to start the game
but um
we'll see what happens obviously it was
definitely
talk about flagrant too it's definitely
one of those so
made the right call there but um
i feel bad for gp like this is his time
to
to shine in a series like this and
play like that knocks him out so
[Music]
it's tough